So now that you've got everything installed, it's ready
to get going with an app Engine App. We've
created a very simple Hello, World app engine application
that uses M-points. You can find it in the
lesson two folder that you downloaded from the [UNKNOWN]
for this course. What we're going to do now, is
import the project into Eclipse. To import a Maven
project into Eclipse, you go up to the Eclipse
menu, you choose file, and then you choose Import.
And you open up the Maven folder and choose Existing
Maven Projects, and then click Next. And then you
can Browse to the folder that has the project that
you want to import. I unzip my folder in
Hello, World endpoints, we have to select the folder itself.
And then if you want, in advanced, you can
specify the name, or you can use the default name.
Make sure that pom.xml's selected. Click Next. You may
see you get some errors. Particularly, the endpoints get discovery
doc. Don't worry about that, just leave it as resolve
later, and say, Finish. It'll ask you, if you have
the error, you'll get a little error message asking you
if you really want to continue. Just say OK, you
do. And then the project comes in. It's a little
hard to see here, but my project is Hello, World.
So this project that you imported, the Hello, World endpoints
project, is a complete working app. It's very simple, but it's
complete. It works, and you can run it out of
the box. So I'm going to show you how to run it
first, and then we're going to look into the code
that makes up the project. So when you're ready to run
your project. Go over here, you choose it. Right-click the project,
choose Run As, and then go ahead and choose Run Configurations.
You can create a new launch configuration,
by clicking this New Launch Configuration button
up here. And enter the Base directory, which is where you project is. But you
can use is variable dollar open brace
project underscore lock. That points the directory where
your project is. The goal, you need to set it to appengin:def server. And down
here in the Maven Runtime, you need to make
sure that the external Maven Runtime is selected. So
it must say external, not internal. If you need
to configure it, then you click Configure, and make
sure that the global settings from installation directory points
to where your Maven is installed. If you can't
remember where your Maven's installed, hop over to a
terminal console window. And hopefully during the Maven installation process,
you defined the variable M2_HOME. So you can
go ahead and just echo that. So say, OK.
And say, Apply. And then right here, I could
go ahead and Run it or I could Close
it. But I'll Run it now. And you see, it starts compiling. And you see here it's
retrieving the Google App Engine Java SDK from Maven.
And that's because in the pump.xml, we specified the
Google App Engine SDK as one of the dependencies. First time
you run it, it does take a while, because Maven has
to go off and get all the libraries and everything that
make up the dependencies in your project. And when it's finished,
you'll see build success. So the build success means, its finished
building. And now it's actually going to start running it. And when
it, when the product is running, the Dev server on local
host, you see this message info, Dev App Server is now running.
So, let's make sure it really is. So open the browser
and go to a new tab, and go to localhost:8080. And if
for any reason your app is running on a different port,
then just use a different port, but I expect it will be
localhost 8080. And look, the app is running. We're not actually
going to run the app, I mean, you're welcome to run it
if you want to, but that's not what we're going to look at
next. So now I just want to show you how to deploy
to app spot. So, back here in the, in Eclipse, go
ahead and select your project, right-click it. Again,
choose Run As and Run Configurations. Click New to add a new configuration.
Again, add the Base directory. And I can
just copy that variable into that new configuration.
Now, this time we want to deploy two app spots. So for that, you have to add
the Goal appengine:update. So here's a goal appengine:update.
Again, make sure the Maven Runtime is says external.
Now you can Run it. Now the first time
you run it, though, you're going to need to
give permission to the App Engine cfg application,
which is an App Engine application that will upload
your App Engine application. And you'll see, that it's
asking permission to view and manage your applications deployed
on Google App Engine. You are going to need
to Accept this. And after you accepted, you'll see
that it shows you a code says, please copy
this code, and paste it. So, go ahead and
copy the entire code, and then go back
to Eclipse. And enter the code. Hit Return. And
it will keep going. Oh, no. Goodness. I got
another error. 403 Forbidden. You do not have permission
to modify this app. App_id=u'your-app-id'. Oh, no wait.
Wait. That's not my app ID. I forgot to
configure the app engine web.mxl. And you're going to
need to do this too. So you go into
the source directory, SRC Source and then into
the main. Not looking at Java just now. You
need to go into the web actor then you need to go into web in inph and you
see app engine web.xml. And this file is
where you can figure the properties are very
specific to App Engine. And the most important
one, for deploying to App Engine is you have
to enter the app ID of your project. And this is the ID that you set in
the developer console, over on console.developers.com. So go
ahead and enter your app ID here, save the
file, and try running again. Now this time, just
go to Run As > Maven build. And pick
the run configuration for App Engine update. I forgot
to na, name mine, but here I see it,
App Engine update. Okay, good. It's beginning the interaction,
see it's initiating, it's cloning, it's uploading. Then it
reaches a point where it's pretty much uploaded stuff,
but it needs to ping the app to verify.
You'll see these messages, will check again in
one, two seconds and so on. And at
this point, all it's really doing is just
trying to ping the app. Can sometimes get hung
here, but usually this doesn't take very long.
Okay, good. So now then again, you see
build success. Now this means, that my apps
been deployed to app spot. Let's go check. So,
to visit your app running on app spot, you
go to your app ID, whatever that is. And
then after you're app ID, you do .appspot.com and
it should take you to your app. And this
looks exactly the same as it did on local
host, but actually we're now running in on app
spot. So, one more thing I wanted to mention
in your project, is that after you deploy it,
whether you deployed it to local host or you deployed
it to app spot, the target directory gets populated with all
the compile code. So, you could actually delete the target
directory, and then re-run your project and it will get recreated.